depuis le premier tour des élections
municipales beaucoup d'événements
inattendus se sont produits cette
pandémie mondiale mais aussi aux
clayes-sous-bois le retrait de la
candidate stéphanie jamin tête de liste
énergie positive c'est donc une
triangulaire pour ce second tour avec
une seule liste de gauche celle de
nicolas eu
il sera opposé à philipp guiguen et
anne-claire frémont sur la liste de
cette dernière figure la maire sortante
véronique côté millard qui a pourtant
préféré soutenir son premier adjoint
philippe guiguen il est arrivé en
première position avec 31 10 68% des
voix lors du premier tour des élections
municipales le taux d'abstention était
de +2 59%
ces trois candidats s'affrontent pour
devenir mère des clayes-sous-bois
commune de 17 1842 habitants on l'a vu
pendant cette crise sanitaire la
nécessité des médecins de ville
mais aux clayes-sous-bois on note une
forte diminution du nombre de praticiens
et les départs en retraite sont non
remplacés
la création d'une maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire est souhaitée pour
pallier cette pénurie de médecins cette
crise sanitaire touche également le
commerce local
les candidats souhaitent soutenir les
producteurs locaux et redynamiser le
commerce de proximité
un problème se pose le stationnement
payant dans le centre ville ou encore
près du centre socioculturel philippe
noiret il est la cause de perte de
fréquentation des commerces de la ville
autres enjeux les objectifs de logements
sociaux à atteindre ils sont de 24,6
pour cent que les sous bois pour un
objectif fixé par la loi de 25% d'ici
2025 les 0 4 % représente une
cinquantaine de logements dans la ville
des futurs logements vont sortir de
terre en 2021
enfin la sécurité la vidéosurveillance
la culture ou encore l'environnement
sont des enjeux importants pour les
clayes-sous-bois